no it's so exciting to be I love you too
and I know it's I know it's the first
day of fall when Trump's colors are at
their peak no really the way his hair
explodes and a riot of golds and reds
and his faces are rich umber and it just
makes you want to get out of the city
and go antiquing in his chins but but
can you believe the years almost shot
again I don't know how this happens I
mean soon the temperatures will be
creeping into the teens
oh wait I'm thinking of Anthony Weiner
he got sent up the river this week
anyway it's a what a week we had so much
destruction the earthquake in Mexico the
hurricane in Puerto Rico the health care
bill in Congress
I mean you watch the Senate go after
health care just month after month they
never give up it's like don't you have
some interns to harass this was their
third attempt now since Trump has been
president to do this this one was
written by Lindsey Graham and it was it
still as we speak is still a few votes
short they don't have it to pass this
monstrosity and today John McCain again
yeah he said he would he would not
support Lindsey's bill so it is a good
day for health care and a bad day for
gay marriage because Lindsey Graham said
I know one maverick who's going to sleep
on the couch tonight
that's all I'm saying
but no john mccain i gotta give to him
he said i cannot in good conscience cut
good conscious vote for such a vague
irresponsible piece of legislation and
all the republicans at once said what's
good conscience but they're learning is
he the problem with the other plans that
they had was that they told the voters
what was in them so they didn't do that
this time they kind of kept it all a big
secret in fact that CBO that's the
Congressional Budget Office which scores
these things they haven't had it long
enough to what they call score it so
they said they can only give it a
partial analysis and the partial
analysis is it's a piece of [ __ ] and but
hey if you think if you think McLin z
are at odds this week boy Trump and
Kim's young gun fat man and little boy
they are feuding again and it meant I
love Kim Hee
he called Trump a dotard which is one of
those words that people have stopped
using like presidential but you know
it's it's from Shakespeare and mr.
president if you're watching Shakespeare
was a guy a long time ago he wrote plays
plays are like a movie but the people
are really there I tell you something
North Korea is not the country that is
on Trump's mind that would be Russia
this Russia investigation I know I say
it everything but it is heating up
Robert Milk Muller says he is very close
to figuring out who in the Trump
campaign was not a Russian spy
[Music]
the things we find out everything Paul
Manafort who was the Trump campaign
manager I know they tried to deny tow he
just came by a few times even he didn't
even really have a desk here yes he did
he was the campaign manager and
apparently he was giving private
briefings to the Russian oligarchs who
were connected to Putin and Trump says I
know that sounds bad but at no time
during the campaign was he ever aware
that he was running for president he
said he only found out about it after
the election by watching Fox and Friends
otherwise but you know they these Ben
they could pretend all they want that
the Russian interference didn't affect
the election but of course it did it did
in a big way in many different ways
including these ads on Facebook have you
seen this [ __ ] that went on and now Mark
Zuckerberg says he has agreed to turn
over over three thousand election ads
that were bought by a Russian troll for
and you know I hope we can at least all
agree that foreigners should not be
influencing our elections if only we had
thought about 20 years ago when an
Australian started Fox News